on a national day of action this is how
police greeted protesters at sri lanka's
parliament
they want the president and his brother
the prime minister to resign
the country faces an economic and
political crisis and the anger that
brought all sections of sri lankan
society to the streets will not be
easily swept aside
they have no solution for this
economic downfall and people are
suffering as a result of that now people
are in the street they are struggling
against this particular government so as
we youth we struggle and we fight for
the peace and we fight for the freedom
we fight for the voiceless people this
is the police line outside the sri
lankan parliament where protests have
been taking place for more than 24 hours
now tensions have risen through the
afternoon and the police used tear gas
and these water cannons to push the
crowds back that worked for a while many
people are not ready to go yet
away from the barricades colombo
shutdown
[Music]
a general strike closed the central
market
workers waiting ready to demonstrate
okay
public transport was closed too the
station crows the only passengers
fuel cues are a constant however
suppliers of diesel and petrol a
precious commodity that the former
energy minister sacked for criticizing
government policy says sri lanka may
soon be unable to afford in near future
we have a risk of being run out of all
kind of all kinds of fuel
what would be the consequences
for the people well
you know immediate situation man without
blood
economy would die
uh situation is terrible basically sri
lanka right now has no foreign currency
reserves whatsoever in coming months
definitely there will be a food shortage
how soon could sri lanka start to run
out of food
one to two months
it's a frightening prospect of course
he's very frightening
[Music]
the focus of public anger
is the slogan of the opposition movement
and there's been a protest camp outside
his office for the past month drawing
young and old poor and professional all
appalled for their country's descent
people
can't afford to get their basic
medicines and not not even even at
a price which they will need to pay
there's no medicines available
at hospitals they turn back people
saying go get the medicines for the
pharmacies and they are even if they go
to pharmacy there's no medicines
available i believe that
this is going to affect every single one
of us eventually and you know because of
the nepotism sri lanka has faced so much
of issues and the situation we are in
right now is due to the mismanagement of
our leaders
the president has now declared a state
of emergency to control protests but
only outside help will stop the economy
imploding
[Music]